I want to be a tough guy Gavin Newsom
says he's not kidding around when it
comes to his threat to lock up Ron
DeSantis the Florida governor testing
newsom's tolerance for being a sanctuary
state after sending him two flights of
migrants to California's capital here's
some whining to the media after claiming
to be inclusive
he's just weakness masquerading his
strength
yeah he's flailing
desperate for attention and he had to go
to another state
to find people under false pretense I
don't think this I know this I talked to
the migrants should he be worried that
law enforcement officials in this state
are going to arrest him when he walks
off the plane and now we're getting into
hyperbole the bottom line is well just
word for responsibility I mean I don't
think it's hyperbole you're the one
raising the issue of criminality
potentially we potentially
well what governor slickster fails to
mention is that everything was voluntary
Florida officials releasing a video
showing they helped migrants in Texas go
to Sacramento and then they had their
verbal and written consent to do so the
migrants even got to go on a party bus
check out the purple lights
Rhonda Santa is punching back at Newsom
the sanctuary jurisdictions are part of
the reason we have this problem because
they have endorsed and agitated for
these types of open border policies and
they have to deal with some of the
fruits of that they all of a sudden
become very very upset about that uh
well what are these people having to
deal with um here I don't see the
sympathy for them kidnap me and put me
on a party bus you know party bus it's
very deceptive it looks like fun but if
you're not wearing a seatbelt it's a
death bus it is it's a death book I
think that now you know what Gavin
Newsome reminds me of when there's
somebody who's on Twitter
who is trying to raise their profile by
coming after somebody and just hitting
him because he knows that DeSantis is
like he's the most effective successful
governor in the United States and and
Gavin's the worst so he's basically you
know he's he's basically heckling him on
Twitter this is what he's doing and it's
a joke because he won't arrest any
thieves he releases you know criminals
early and he wants and now he's
threatening you know to yeah he puts on
his ax body spray but when buttons a
shirt now he's you know Rocky Balboa
going after Whatever by the way he is
wrong too illegal immigration is a poor
sport or is not a local issue it's a
national issue and it's not a stunt to
marry a national problem with the
national issue which is what those buses
did if Newsome is too chicken to step up
and pitch in and help these other
Governors which is what in a National
Emergency you would do he should go back
to the French Laundry and yell at the
mask to help while slurping on foie gras
the I believe it was an MSNBC anchor
good for him he's like you're the one
that brought up kidnapping yep yep no I
love that look even yesterday I think it
was yesterday we spoke about this I said
I don't even want to talk about the
statute I mean that's just ridiculous
but you know it's interesting um Newsom
is criticizing Ron DeSantis Rhonda
santis has a state that has added 319
000 Americans people who want to give up
where they're living to go live in
Florida Gavin Newsom as a state where
343 000 are moving out because they hate
California and for good reason I mean if
you go to San Francisco one of the most
beautiful cities in America I mean you
take your life in your hand I mean
forget about it and it is it is Gavin
Newsom it's just the guy trying to get
attention he's the little guy and you
know he is consistently he is
consistently freed people directly
without even involving the parole board
I mean you know he wants to criticize
Ron DeSantis but but that whole idea
they have the consent forms everybody
had a good time and this is a classic
the administration the Democrats were
Sanctuary cities God bless all of you
come to us until they have to walk the
walk and he's just picking an issue to
try to make a name for himself it's
absurd politically why does Gavin Newsom
go after Ron DeSantis why doesn't he go
after Donald Trump
well I don't I don't know the answer to
that what I I understand that I think
what motivates your question I I don't
understand why adults can't be leaders
uh the two of them have been elected to
lead two of the most important states in
the country if not two of the three most
important states in the country both of
them are reflections of their respective
parties they seem to be more committed
to the to the cathartic than they are to
the Strategic we have a problem it's
obvious what the problem is we talk
about it around this table often I think
intelligently I think with some
enthusiasm and sometimes with a little
disagreement these guys only want to
engage in stunts and it's it's it it's
frustrating and maddening because we've
outlined the elements of a solution here
and for some reason and there are others
that are too even Robert F Kennedy Jr
who went down to the Border gave us
pictures and gave some narrative around
how we could begin to solve some of
these problems I hope I hope they get a
little what they want to get out of it
both Newsome and DeSantis to try to
advance their own personal political
local agendas and political athletic
personas but you're not doing anything
anything to help those migrants that
you're concerned about nor are we doing
anything to protect our border and Gavin
could be attacking the president
so it's pretty convenient to go after
Ron DeSantis yeah I
agree with Greg I think this is all
exercise to elevate himself I think he
is preparing to fill a void should avoid
a rise I think a lot of people wonder
whether or not President Biden although
he obviously has declared that he's
running for president again and that's
the current status of his political
situation
I think a lot of people wonder whether
or not he actually will in the end and
so I think you see Gavin Newsom saying
I'm going after DeSantis he's young like
me he's a successful Governor from
another state and I'm also serving my
party if I can ding him in this process
and you know let have Donald Trump be
the candidate I believe that Democrats
think that Donald Trump might be the
easier person for them to run against
whether or not that's true I don't know
but I think this is a very deeply
political and sort of and completely
driven by his own political ambition he
only gets pressed when he attacks Rhonda
absolutely
Victoria city he should be saying oh
thank you so much for sending them on
the buses because this is exactly what I
said I wanted you can say you're cruel
Ron will take care of these people
if he's not a hypocrite yes all right up
next Squad member Corey Bush thinks if
you're against going woke you're a
racist hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else